welcome back
to the podcast hello everybody
welcome on in everybody uh
i see that there's a few of you so uh
everybody sprint in
and not single file line just everybody
sprinting at once
sprint full sprint and no one should get
hurt it should all be fine so just come
on
faster and um
there we go good the capacity
for this area is like five or ten
but we can stretch it today so
everyone's welcome come come come faster
faster
anyway welcome to the podcast guys i
hope you're having a wonderful monday
today i'm joined
by another wonderful guest wow what is
this three weeks in a row
of guests squirp the soap hand
has uh decided to make an appearance on
the podcast
squirt how you doing
i think squirt's pretty happy to be here
just been
actually kind of the mvp the last few
months keeping us clean
keeping our germs far far away
thank you squirt for uh protecting us i
hope you're feeling like you're uh
you're doing okay and doing some
self-care because i know you're
you're really worried about us but just
happy to see you
and nice to see that little smile
anyway uh this episode is brought to you
by stitch fix guys when you want
new clothes but you don't want to pick
them out yourself you'd rather someone
who's paid to pick them out
pick them out for you go to stitch fix
you get your own personal styles it's
awesome
it's an online personal styling service
that finds and delivers clothes
shoes and accessories that fit your body
budget and style so right now go to
stitch fix dot com slash jenna julian
that's stitchfix.com slash channel again
extra 25
off when you keep keep everything in
your box check them out
also guys squarespace if you wanted to
start a new website whether for a hobby
or a business do it with squarespace
they make it so much easier there's so
many awesome tools to make the
experience of building website a fun
and pleasant one so right now go to
squarespace.com to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain and if you're not ready to buy
yet
you do a free trial and see how you like
it
also the links for those are down below
um so
hello um
just wanted to quickly touch on
the fact elephant in the room i'm alone
again right this is just me
and i know a lot of you are commenting
each week and asking on twitter and
where's jenna when is she coming back
what's going on i miss her
uh and i wanted to address that in a way
that i felt like was healthy and not
speaking for her and not
um making an episode about it but i do
want to just
i wanted to say um
she has no plans to come back to the
podcast she's stepping away
um and she's taking care of herself and
i know that for us doing this for so
many years
you get used to something you get used
to listening to two voices you'll get
used to hearing both of us have
conversations you get
used to seeing her uh and so to go from
that a lot of that to none of that is is
jarring and i i totally get that and i
want you to unders
you understand that i empathize with
those of you who miss her and are
confused and
but the bottom line is is the reality of
it is she's not here she's not gonna
come back
um at least for the for the very
foreseeable
very foreseeable future um so i wanted
to just like
address that a little bit and also let
you know that i don't
actually have all the answers as far as
uh the podcast and
moving forward with the podcast and how
it's all going to look and feel
and how long i'm going to be doing
this content and if i'm going to change
the content is it going to be
in a different place and is it going to
you know is it going to have another
person it's like
there's just so many there there's a lot
of variables and there's a lot of
question marks as to
what's going to happen mainly with the
podcast is what i'm talking about
uh because we're on the podcast and i
just want you to know that i don't have
all the answers
what i do have right now is
the wherewithal to come in here each
week
uh sit down and try to prepare a little
bit of content for you so that you're
not left empty-handed
because i know you um at least some of
you not all of you
are enjoying me making content here
solo so that's what i can do
and um
hopefully in time i'll have more answers
and i'll have the right ones as far as
what to expect next from me
in a podcast form if there is anything
to expect
uh what to expect uh or what you can
plan on seeing in the future for this
specific channel
you know what i mean there's just um
there will be more answers in time and i
just don't have them all right now so i
want you guys to know that i'm aware of
the fact that
you know it's just me i'm not trying to
pretend like
this is all normal because it's not i'm
just doing my best to carry on and to
keep moving forward
and
you know uh i'm just trying to be
honest with you guys trying to be
transparent i'm trying to
you know that's what this whole this
whole thing has
been about for me for the last i don't
know six seven years of being on the
internet is
being a real person and you know talking
to you guys like you're real people
not treating you like you're um
your kids or something or you don't
deserve to know answers of things or we
don't
you know have the right to talk about
real life or things like that you know i
try to treat you as equals and and i
think this is a situation that and
very much includes that dynamic so that
is what i'm doing right now anyway
um that's kind of where i'm at i hope
for some of you maybe just a small
handful of you probably i answered a
little bit
of um you know some of what you were
wondering is going on and
um maybe even just me talking about it
made it a little bit better for you i
don't know could have made it worse i
apologize
but um i'm just uh i'm gonna do some
some fun content where i can find the
ability to make it
here for for the time being and we'll
see how it goes
so all right with that said
um i
i got a suggestion on discord which i
told you i was gonna link the discord
last week and didn't link it so let's
see if i remember this week it'll be a
fun game i told you
uh that was linked so yeah but um i was
looking through suggestions on discord
and i found
one that i know is not like original to
one podcast or this wouldn't be nearly
the first podcast or anything like that
to do it i know a lot of people have
probably done it
um but i thought it was a really funny
idea
and the idea is to gather some of your
secrets
and read them on a podcast anonymously
of course
so i spent uh the better part of my
afternoon
going on and i used instagram because
there's like an
anonymous um answer form fill out
feature
well it's not anonymous like i see who
you are but it's not public it's like a
mini dm kind of thing
um and i gathered secrets
oh i gathered them and you all have some
[ __ ] crazy secrets jesus let me tell
you
uh so what
what oh squirt squirt made a little
comment
i agree squirt it's just
crazy out there you know uh so i
literally thought why not just read some
of your secrets on
on the podcast um also one more note uh
talking about what i was going over in
the beginning
the podcast might be a little shorter um
i don't want
you to be listening to an hour of me
trying to fill an hour
sometimes i'm i'm just not i don't feel
like i have an hour's worth of content
so they might be a little short of
moving forward i hope you guys can
understand that
uh anyway i
my photo library on my phone right now
hoo boy it is riddled with secrets
like juicy juicy secrets
and i'm gonna go through some of them
i'm just gonna read them and i'll give
you a couple thoughts and maybe just
no thoughts for some of them and move on
and uh
hopefully we can all be okay obviously
i'm not going to be reading their names
because the whole purpose of this
exercise and game is to um
air anonymous laundry i guess you could
say
okay first one
all right when i was younger i used to
collect fingernails
all right well we're off to a strong
start i have a few questions i wonder if
these
were you know your fingernails
like you would cut your fingernails
gather them up and instead of tossing
them in the trash you toss them in
your fingernail shoe box in the closet
right that's that's pretty weird but
it's also like and do what you want i
don't
it's your shoebox you know i don't it's
your collection i used to collect things
but were they other people's
and i really hope the answer to the
second part is no but if it's yes i am
not going to judge you i just
how how would you even collect other
people's fingernails
like did you just develop a sense of
like hearing that clicking sound and
anytime you heard that
like that snapping of the nail cutter
like in the house you're like oh
someone's cutting their nails i better
go
try to sneak a few for my collection
all right next one if my ex acts
if my ex asked me i would have married
him
okay so i i saw a lot of secrets that
were involving something like this
where it would say something like you
know i miss my ex
or um i shouldn't have broken up with my
ex or
i think about my ex you know things like
that and i
want to off the top even though this is
sort of like a jokey you know
entertaining podcast like that's
you know anything i say like take with a
grain of salt here all right because
we're just here
you know making a podcast but and i
don't know your life but
um that's that's a lot that's
that's a lot to hear the someone said
if my ex were to have asked me i would
have married them now i have a lot of
questions like
it like are you with someone else new or
um are they with someone else new did
you break up with them did they break up
with you
do you still talk how long ago did you
break up how close were you do you think
to maybe getting married like
all those questions are i feel like
important and something like this but
either way that's that's something that
like
clearly is affecting a person like
much time later maybe thinking about
that
if if they had only if they'd only
popped the question
you would have said yes but again like i
also
think that like i'm a firm believer in
relationships being strong because
they're strong
not being strong because they got
married or had kids
and i know plenty of people in
relationships who have
incredible strong admirable
relationships who aren't married and i
know
plenty of people you know who have been
married
or who are married who maybe don't have
the best relationship so like my opinion
is that marriage isn't
like shoulda coulda would have gotten
married and everything would have been
fine like they're your ex there's
probably a reason or
for more than a few reasons that they're
your ex
but i don't know that's just me judging
but you sent me your secrets so i get to
do that
i have a pet snake under my bed but if
my family finds out i'll get kicked out
how do you how do you have a pet snake
under your bed
first of all what
how did you get that thing in the house
is it okay there must be a terrarium
like you can't just have that living
loose under your bed there's no way
the pet snake would there's no way that
thing is trained well enough to just not
leave
i think the only reason why this is even
remotely believable is because
i think a snake at least like a boa
constrictor
or like a garter snake they're so quiet
that like
i guess as far as pets go like
you could those are probably the most
concealable
i had a garter snake when i was a kid my
sister had
multiple boa constrictors
but my family knew about it it wasn't a
secret i think
from experience though the smell
i think a boa constrictor if it's a big
snake i'd be [ __ ] impressed
also you what you're bringing in live
mice to feed that thing and your parents
don't know that you're just walking
through the house with a bunch of
mice food
also how do you know you get kicked out
is it like a no snake household
like is that on the rule the rule board
in the household
or is it just because you're hiding a
reptile from
your immediate family while living there
rent free
but you're probably a child i
i don't know i have a lot of questions
i accidentally broke my mom's watch that
she had from her late father when i was
seven
and she put the monkey emoji where the
monkey's covering his eyes
damn damn
um that sucks
but i will also say that
it is you know it's a sentimental
sentimentally valued item for your mom
probably
but it's it is just an item right items
can
come and go they're not they're not the
end of the world if you lose them it
sucks for sure
i do relate to this though i think i've
actually told the story on the podcast
before
when i was young my dad
showed me a ken griffey side baseball
that he had
which is a very prized possession of his
at the time he's like hey son
who plays baseball i was maybe i was
very young i was probably like six or
seven
maybe even eight i don't know he's like
check out this baseball signed by ken
griffey
i saw him i saw him sign it he signed it
for me
and i remember looking at it one day and
i was like
wow he did like a really shitty job like
yeah i get he's like a big deal he can
hit
he can hit you know home runs but like
what's the deal with this color on the
ink that he used it's like light blue
it's
faded this is no press position so i was
like
i got an idea i grabbed the ballpoint
pen and i just
traced over the whole signature just
very neatly
i actually think i could probably blame
my mom for this one because she was the
one who was an artist
tommy had to uh draw and write in
lettering and
calligraphy so um no i i traced over the
whole signature and my dad like
flipped out when he found out he was
like why the [ __ ] would you do that
why why child of mine did you just
destroy my dreams
oh boy oh boy
i sold a kidney this year to pay for
tuition and i've managed to keep it a
secret so far
that is so that is so impressive
there's so many parts of this that's
just incredible to me if it's true
the fact that i know nothing about what
that process is like
but the fact that you educated yourself
enough to know that you could do it
probably with not that much downtime
because it sounds like you're like still
in school
you can't like be incapacitated to where
someone has to care for you and if even
if you were
it wasn't your family that cared for you
so it might have been like a roommate or
a friend
you researched how that would go you had
the wherewithal to find a place that you
trusted
to do it you paid for no you don't pay
for obviously they pay
they pay you but is there any medical
bills that you have to cover
no they probably cover it right
otherwise why would you sell a kidney
and then making sure you'd be healthy
after something like that and then
keeping it all secret
but i think the most baller part of this
is that you did that to pay for your
tuition like holy [ __ ] dude
what the hell like where did you even
do your research did you just like
google
how like how to sell a kitty i mean
honestly i bet you could probably
learn all you needed online like why do
you even need
anything else how to sell a kitty and
then just don't tell your family i guess
maybe you have an oblivious family
though maybe they're just like not keen
to it
i'm curious how much you would make from
that i should look on
on the internet about that the internet
full of websites
websites probably built by squarespace
this episode is brought to you by
squarespace our friends at squarespace
always making it fun and easy for you
guys
to build your own website whether it's a
your main gig or your side hustle
uh building a website is now easy and
fun and you can make it beautiful and if
you have questions while you're doing it
they have an amazing 24 hour day seven
day a week uh
customer live support so if you're
building voice in the middle of the
night and you're like no one's gonna be
around to help me nope squarespace is
around to help you
uh they have customer support around the
clock award-winning customer support
mind you
that helps get you off of any snag that
you might run into while building the
website they have
really really sophisticated blogging
capabilities
they have the ability to set up an
online store or shop
within your website you can design it
with any color or template you like
i mean you can really customize this
thing you can make it look
nice okay so uh check it out
by going to squarespace.com jenna julian
it is a drag and drop
visual website builder by the way so
it's much easier than you think
building a website is uh squarespace.com
get 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain or just go to
squarespace.com and tr
try a free trial that's fine you can try
that but once you decide you want to do
it use our url and you get 10 off your
first purchase of a website or domain or
click the link down below
speaking of down below don't you need
some new pants right well stitchfix is
there for you okay
it is a service that assigns a personal
online professional stylist to your
account okay you fill out
a couple of questions when you sign up
for stitch fix all right
your size the styles you like all of
this is added to your profile
right then you send the information to
them and what happens is
there's no subscription required what
happens is they take
all that information they give it to
their stylists and they completely
compile an entire box for your wardrobe
and they send it to you
and you get it you're like damn i really
feel like someone knows who i am
bought this for me this isn't no random
gift bag here this is for me
uh and if for whatever reason you don't
like some stuff or all of it you can
send it back you don't have to keep it
it's like
it's not on you to just keep everything
but
you will get a 25 off discount when you
go to stitchfix.com
and you keep everything in the box that
code that account
um sorry that discount applies when you
keep everything in your box so
it's you know there are pros and cons to
keeping everything in your box but again
if
something doesn't fit or something's not
right you can have them take it back and
it's not on you you don't have to like
pay for it
uh so check it out it's a really cool
way to shop honestly especially right
now you try all the clothes on
look in the mirror see what you like
take a couple pics snap a couple
you know go to uh stitchfix.com
and julian get an extra 25 off and keep
everything in your box
get started now click the link down
below awesome service
all right well to the person who sold a
kidney to pay for their education
hyper clap that's impressive
staying home during the pandemic has
been one of the best things to happen to
me
this one isn't much of a shocker to be
honest i feel like uh
i feel like that's not far out
i can see why quarantine
affects people very differently excuse
me
i feel like you know most of what you
see
is generally people like oh man i want
to go to the beach i want to leave my
house i'm you know i'm used to being
social
this just fell off my chair that's fun
cool
i don't need that uh you know
that's like the general like public
opinion that
you'd be used to reading but there's so
many different types of people who
thrive in so many different types of
social situations
and maybe thrive in so many types of
anti-social situations and honestly i i
find myself in the category of the
latter
um because i feel like
i uh i'm used to being
kind of secluded a little bit i have the
internet and i have my person i have my
pets but i don't
even when the world is normal i don't
remember just constantly surrounding
myself with people that's just not what
i do so
you saying you've you know you it's been
one of the best things to happen to you
staying home i can get why that feels a
little taboo to say because of all of
what's going on so
people might take that as like oh you're
great you're grateful that people are
dying of cover like that's not what
you're saying
um interesting though this is an
interesting one
this one says i'm happily engaged but i
still miss my ex-husband
another one like uh like the one we read
earlier where
it deals with the x situation and the
complicated feelings
when moving forward from a relationship
and looking back
towards your past relationships
again take my judgment with a grain of
salt because this is a podcast and we're
here for
lighthearted fun but when you say you're
happily engaged
and in the same sentence you say you
miss your ex-husband
putting myself in the shoes of your
current partner
i don't know that i would believe you
when you said
i'm happily engaged uh i know that
there's a lot of angles to it and i'm
not saying you're
a good or bad person for that obviously
i'm not you know
everyone has feelings things are
complicated but
um i do feel like this is a little bit
of a contradiction i'm happily married
but i also mix my mismatch
seems like a bit of a contradiction like
if you were to say that to your husband
in super honesty time you're like hey i
love you and i'm happily engaged to you
and i love the ring and i'm happy you
know but i really miss my ex
first of all boy don't do that
don't say that to him because i feel
like that you have a chance of like
really destroying him
because i would i mean i don't know how
i would take something like that that's
rough
um also maybe you worded it wrong here i
still miss my ex maybe you have
kind of um
a little bit romanticized memories of
your last relationship
maybe you think back to it and you only
remember the good stuff
and to be honest there was a lot of
maybe not so good stuff that you're not
really remembering
right now uh because it's been some time
and the pain isn't
right there and there's a lot of angles
to this but i hope you figure it out
and
well the next one is very similar i
don't love my boyfriend anymore this one
feels a lot more cut and dry
and it's not a contradiction this one's
just i don't love my boyfriend anymore
nothing about this is easy though i'm
not saying this is like an easier
topic to deal with um thank you for
sharing your secret with me i
i mean my advice my unsolicited advice
this is kind of an unsolicited advice
podcast
what oh
squirt's making fun of me because i'm
giving advice and you didn't ask for it
squip i'm just giving unsolicited advice
as part of the podcast
why don't you look at me when you talk
to me at least jeez
so judgy what you're perfect
um as a boyfriend
i would think that the sooner you can
tell this person
how you feel the better for everyone and
i know it's very hard
and it's probably not a conversation
that you want to have and i also know
that in relationships even the ones that
aren't great and there are
problems with them and there may be some
toxicity sometimes it feels like it's
easier to stay
you know what i mean there's like your
family knows them their family knows you
you live together you share a pet i mean
there's so many different
complications that could come with a
relationship that doesn't make a
a decision to break up nearly as easy as
you'd hope or you thought it would be at
one point
but i do think the sooner you get going
on that band-aid ripping off is
is the better for both of you
one time i got too drunk to leave my
room
and i peed in a litter box but i cleaned
it up
i like the second part of this where
it's just like no but i cleaned it up
i swear i didn't leave it in there um
hey man a plus for resourcefulness
i i feel like i've never peed in a
litter box
um i also
don't know if i mean
obviously peeing in your room is not
good but
it's less it's less bases to cover than
walking down the hall and going to the
bathroom so
you're already cutting out so many steps
by just peeing in your room i wonder if
the the angle of peeing in a small
litter box would kind of balance out
that difficulty but it sounds like you
had no problem
sounds like you just went cleaned it up
and literally no one ever knew except
for me and now everyone who's listening
to this podcast
and everyone whoever finds this podcast
in the history of the internet as long
as it's less
so no big deal but congrats on that
sounds honestly like
a drunk mistake that led to a little bit
of an accomplishment maybe
i make different social media accounts
to follow my friends
i use the accounts to hype them up dude
that's what i'm talking about
that's a friend right there you make
secret alt accounts
to go and gas up your friends so that
they feel good i mean
that is a friend i want you on my team
whoever you are i like that
i like that not enough people like you
using social media for good like that
you're a hero
thank you
i blamed my brother for the simpsons
porn on my parents laptop when i was 10
it was me
simpsons porn
oh no and your parents saw that and you
told you
told me it was your brother and then
your brother's like a deer in the
headlights
a simpsons porn watching deer in the heb
i can't even say it dude oh god
damn you really [ __ ] did it to him
you pinned the ultimate crime it's not
just like porn that they found it's
simpson's porn so now
so now every single time you're growing
up from
from when you were 10 to like when you
leave the house
any time the family's in the living room
watching the simpsons
he is [ __ ] he is on trial and he
doesn't even know it he doesn't even
know why
man he is he really did it too
my boyfriend uh painted my kitchen
cabinets while i was away to surprise me
four years later and i still hate them
this one this one makes me sad not like
a real sad like it's obviously trivial
just turn face the camera it's just
trivial because it's
you know they're cabinets you can always
replace them and paint them and whatever
they're not permanent
but i do get why this is something that
you kept for four years because you
don't want to hurt the person that
a that you love and be that cares about
you enough to surprise you with a cool
thing like this
like a i i think everyone
in a relationship at some point can can
empathize with your position here
um of like not wanting to hurt your
person's feelings
especially because they went through so
much to make you happy and you know that
they did it
for you even though the the result isn't
what you wanted
it's like the thought that counted but
you're still stuck with those cabinets
so you're like the thought was cool
my advice unsolicited is
to bring it up
and say hey i love you and you're
wonderful
and i think you're so sweet for wanting
to surprise me
uh with these cabinets while i was gone
and i haven't had the
guts to bring it up to you because i
didn't want to hurt your feelings but i
honestly just don't love the way they
came out and i would love to maybe redo
them together
and i still just really appreciate that
you went out of your way
to surprise me with them i don't know i
feel like it might sting a little bit
but
they'll get over it i have an only fans
under a fake name
i'm not reading the name even though
they sent it which is actually what my
name
should be
hmm or maybe it's like a last name that
you should have had but you don't
um only fans under a fake name
i wonder how many people do that i feel
like a lot
i feel like unless you're a person in
the public eye
let's just take like a twitch streamer
okay
their person the a person who streams on
twitch is a public
figure they have a first and last name
or
their username on twitch which is like
i don't know like one word that is their
gamer name
but usually usually this isn't for every
situation their
their real name is out there it's like
public knowledge so they'd be like yeah
i'm starting only fans
this is my name obviously but aside from
people in a situation where they like
they're publicly known i wouldn't blame
you know people for starting only fans
under fake names i feel like that's
probably the way to do it
reduce your chances of getting caught by
your friends and family
when i was in fourth grade i used to
secretly suck on my cousin's big toe
when she slept
oh
damn they had us in the first half i'm
not gonna lie
oh boy um
who i don't know what to say about this
fourth grade huh
did you just regularly sleep head to toe
with your cousin
or was this just like an occasional
thing
damn they really had us in the first
half dude i don't know i
i don't even know what to say about that
i'm moving on uh i pooped myself on a
trampoline
and hid the poop in my garden
well that just sounds like a dope ass
garden party to me
also thank you for fertilizing the
plants i'll say that for your mom and
dad because
they clearly didn't say thanks
how do you poop on a trampoline what do
you what even does that look like
what the hell is even that you're just
like jumping and jumping and then all of
a sudden something else is jumping next
to you and you're like hey i'm gonna put
you in the garden
i wear my jeans at least four times
before watching them
uh me
me too is that not normal
am i supposed to wash my jeans every
time i wear them that's cut
oh am i weird
i don't think you're weird i think jeans
are made to be watched only a couple
times
you know you skip wash cycles with those
suckers all right
they're made to last and they need they
need to be worn in and weathered a
little bit
i only watch the office and new girl on
netflix because anything different makes
me too
anxious this is something i can also
relate to i think
uh i do i do uh you know try my best to
venture out into new shows into new
programs even like reading books i've
been reading
a little lately which is something new
for me i haven't done that in a lot of
years
but i try to i try to like deviate from
the norm of like watching the office
parks and rec and breaking bad
on repeat forever until i'm dead because
i know that
first of all it's hard and i empathize
with that big time because i feel that
same
anxiety i know it's trivial because it's
like what are you watching but at the
same time
there's this sense of comfort there's a
sense of normalcy with the shows that
you know and love
um i actually think i was watching a
binging with babish video it was like
one of those um
everything a person does in a day and he
was talking about how he rewatches parks
and rec and um
other other shows i forget what the
other shows were
um frasier and he was he he described it
as
watching shows over and over until you
until you die just forever
just constantly rewatching them on your
free time
you do it like people listen to music
and i think that makes perfect sense
when you think about it like that
because honestly it's familiar sound
it's sound that makes you feel something
that you enjoy
it's um and that's so important right
that's why people listen to music it
makes you feel something and it's
familiar usually
so i don't i don't think this is um
something to be
ashamed about at all i do the same thing
although what i was saying is i do
i do try lately and i have tried lately
to venture out and
really just kind of get through the
first episode of a new series because i
know that's hard
it's it you have to apply yourself a lot
more you're not like relaxed totally
you're just kind of you're like
trying to see if it's good and you're
trying to pay attention and
um but i relate to this one i relate to
this one
uh when people see my copy of stuck on
you that you signed i never tell them
that you weren't in the movie
nice i like your style and i remember
you
um i met this person on a last minute
trip outside of uh
st louis at a gas station and
uh they were looking for us because we
were like you know tweeting where we
were while we filmed
and we were taking a picture and then
she [ __ ] whips out
a copy of stuck on you and says will you
sign this
you you got to tell him that i'm the
main character right
i like that
i'm super in love with my boyfriend but
i'm waiting for him to say it first
because i'm scared help
okay so squirt you can't rag on me
because this is actually solicited
advice
they said help so we need to help them
by the way chime in at any time
um the first time you and your
partner say i love you to each other um
i think is one of those things that like
movies have
built up to be this like kind of
over important thing that's not really
that important
and i don't mean like loving someone is
not important i mean that moment of like
who says it first
and like getting rejected after you know
say you say it they don't say it back
like that's real like that situation
sucks i'm not saying that's not a real
risk you're taking when you say i love
you but i think in my mind and in my
experience
movies and tv have always like kind of
warped me to think like it's
way more of a big deal than it actually
is when it happens
i don't know like if you feel like this
person loves you and
if you feel like they're your person and
you
are in love with them i think maybe
saying i love you
and like whenever you're ready to say it
back or if you never say it back i can
figure out a way to deal with that but i
just need you to know that i love you
you know it's putting yourself out there
though i understand why that's hard i do
understand that's hard
i once broke a plate while getting water
from my chickens
and blamed it on the chickens what the
hell dude the chickens didn't do
anything to you
now who whoever lives there is just like
these [ __ ] chickens dude all they do
is break plates
and eat our grass and drink our water
what a bunch of dick chickens dude it's
all because of you who broke the plate
and you blamed it on the helpless
chickens they don't even speak
a language they can't even defend
themselves
damn i sell feet pics
on to people on reddit and actually have
made decent money
cry laughing emoji
[ __ ] make that paper make that paper
my dude
i don't i mean who am i to [ __ ] judge
get that money
gotta be creative right now
i don't think that there's anything
wrong with this honestly um does that
make me weird
i would say though if you're with
someone i don't know
maybe eventually telling them i don't
know maybe not
i think what the weirdest situation
would be is you don't tell your
significant other that you're selling
feed picks
they end up with a foot fetish they go
to buy feed picks online
they buy your fee picks they receive
them and they recognize your email
address and they're like wait a minute
you're you
that's probably unlikely
i flew to another country to have an
affair with a married man
after his wife got arrested for selling
drugs
what you did what
oh
okay well i hope everyone involved is
okay
um
this one i don't even know
this feels like a movie plot
it was like crazy in the first part and
then the arrested for selling drugs is
like the cherry on top
of crazy damn
what the hell uh well damn yeah some of
you all have some crazy [ __ ] lives
and some of you all have some relatable
problems i would say
so don't feel weird about it and
um thank you for being open and sharing
sharing uh your secrets with me i
honestly feel
i should delete this post so i'm not
continuously getting secrets i'm gonna
delete the post
thank you to everyone who submitted uh a
secret
uh as a reply to our instagram story
because we
you know this is like this is the [ __ ] i
like doing honestly
because uh now that i'm solo on the
podcast it's nice to have
you guys to interact with whether it's
like the dink cast
with the uh or the dink tank or
reading your secrets uh these are the
type of like i i like these ideas so if
you have any more ideas like this
please let me know in the comments um
but yeah thank you to everyone i know
there's a lot of people who submitted
secrets
uh your secrets are safe with me i
promise okay i'm deleting them from my
phone now
and you won't have to worry about it but
thank you for being brave enough to
trust me
with your precious secrets and giving
them
as this content present to the podcast
our podcast thanks you the dinks thank
you
anyway uh i hope all of you have a
wonderful week uh i hope i was able to
kind of clarify the situation a little
bit more and um
kind of give you an update of where i'm
at and uh
i really really really appreciate you
for hanging out still
if you're still here means a lot and uh
just thank you for for sticking with us
and sticking with me means a lot so have
a wonderful week
i'll see you guys on the next podcast
and i'll see you all
week long streaming live on twitch if
you want to hang out with me there
that's probably we have a lot of fun uh
so
yeah be good happy monday and i'll see
you next week
[Music]
you